[Music]
in the 1800s the motion picture was born
with the Advent of synchronized sound
film entered a golden age
now just as Nicole Kidman welcomes us
back to theaters we can count ourselves
among the lucky few who are blessed to
be alive during the true peak of Cinema
[Music]
this is
the jackass movies
when some skaters realize that not
everybody cares about kickflips but
everyone loves a nutshot jackass was
born growing from its humble roots in
the CKY and Big Brother videos to
becoming the top rated show on MTV back
when that actually meant something
jackass would find its highest
expression on the big screen with a
debut that used a bigger budget to
really Elevate the material
a sequel that proved the series is no
ball
the third one that's yeah I'll say it a
better use of 3D than Avatar
and ah screw it a legacy sequel that's
more nostalgic than all the nerd
franchises combined
glad when Andrew Garfield stepped out in
the spider suit I clapped when Dave
England stepped out in his pooping
cardigan
ah Cinema meet the jackasses
a bunch of clowns and the world is their
circus there's ringleader Johnny
Knoxville a failed actor That's a
classic who turned into a stunt band who
turned back into a failed actor who
turned back into a stunt man
[Applause]
Margera who has the perfect mixture of
Genius stupidity and sadism to take
ideas from good to great we have a
weight going up and it's supposed to hit
me in the nuts but I'd prefer to have
like instead of the weight and then
instead of the nuts it'll be my Ryan
Dodd whose death left a void not even
four Zoomers and a guy named poopies
could fill
they already know that too many people
Steve Earle whose early stunts feel like
watching an addict hit their low point
but his later stunts are even harder to
watch because my God how could you do
that sober
Chris Pontius a wild boy who's keeping
sketchy animal handlers in business
there's no doubt in my mind when you hit
a ball full bees you're gonna get stuff
well I made the mistake of showing them
what sea cucumbers do when they're
threatened venomous
keeping the animal kingdom well-fed
[Music]
Preston Lacy and Jason we manicuna who
dedicated their lives to exploring mass
and gravity
Dave England who has the closest thing
to a character Arc by going from guy who
freaked out during beehive tetherball
to guy who stood pretty still during
beehive penis ball
[Laughter]
and danger Aaron who proves that if
you're not as cute or famous as the
others you're probably going to get
stuck doing the worst talk to it Aaron
try to calm it down oh no it's going for
the salmon
Nails right now he's teasing
foreign
gets paid more for these things or at
least some dental insurance
want to see something that will scar you
for life great cause every Jackass movie
has at least one of those moments
but the thing that makes jackass better
than the obviously fake prank shows the
amateur stunt YouTubers and all the
other people that they've influenced is
the simple joy of watching a bunch of
lifelong friends hang out and goof off
together oh isn't it so wholesome how
they all cheer and hug after every stunt
makes me wish I was part of their family
uh maybe an uncle or something
okay how about a job behind the camera
nope never mind no place is safe so pop
your shirt off and enjoy the last
remaining slapstick comedy franchise
it's yojiang mid what healthy
masculinity looks like I can't take them
off your move unless you give me
permission and makes us all feel a bit
more comfortable in our own skin and
that is still on our bodies
[Applause]
because while these guys are no longer
that young they'll always be dumb what's
antidote mean I don't even know was the
dick hair necessary absolutely I don't
know I'm stupid and still full of well
you know I was rubbing horse on my face
for weeks to set up
why are you looking at me like that
oh no I can't even get a card on
it was water
I'm a vegetarian
that's bleach
starring the best recurring bits in
these movies permanent bodily harm
this is a total smiley face dude
[Music]
fun with dioramas
[Applause]
foreign
when the jocks get to hang with the
skaters for the day
there you go
Bam's weird Mumble voice intros and this
is the brand
and it's gonna suck I just lost a load
of fans but I gained four in Key West
and they're heavy looks like Dunn's up
next fat Fashion's hungry for some
chocolate so now I'm gonna feed them and
the funniest joke of all the disclaimer
the stunts in this movie were performed
by professionals
pain strains and oh God my balls
[Music]
Simpsons did it
foreign
[Music]
ever wonder which one of the jackass
crew gets hurt the most pulls off the
most pranks literally eats the most we
break down everyone's career stats in a
new episode of Jackass by the Numbers
click the thumbnail on the right to see
who wins
hello I'm epic voice guy and welcome to
the end card section dab on the haters
69420 blaze it I can't take it anymore
if I gotta choke down on one more of
those moldy disgusting crackers bam
whack and that's the bottom line because
Stone Cold said so